can you tell us about shopping around
one of your first feature films
that you and your collaborators wrote i
think it's called is it waiting for
tomorrow
yes yeah yeah waiting for tomorrow is uh
that was a we we wrote this this script
um and we worked on it
for i think we took about eight it took
about a year to write the full script
and get it really polished to where we
wanted it
and we worked on that we chopped that
thing around for about three years
and it was about three years of people
going
this script is great but no
nothing on the back end it was a lot of
you know we we did a lot of
uh screws we did some uh screenwriting
competitions and and it was very
successful there and
we thought well maybe that's enough to
sort of get more people to you know and
we would talk to you know we have
friends who are producers who run
companies and and you know have more
money than we do and
and they would read it and they would go
oh this is great like you know we would
love to do something like this so it was
a lot of it was just
getting the script out to a lot of
people that
we knew you know like this this type of
content
um so it was about a three year process
of getting it out and it wasn't until
like the last year that we started to
get actually
started to get a lot of traction and you
know we were getting
uh you know a lot of phone calls and
emails about it and and
and we were getting you know responses
from sort of bigger names and
and and and people that have read it and
always really
really really love it you know they're
you know actors might be busy at the
time or you know scheduling
uh is difficult especially in in
in the film industry but so yeah it was
a lot of we started to get
all of this sort of traction with it and
that led us to
getting more people involved and more
people saying okay well we can give you
x amount of dollars and we can give you
x amount of dollars and then
the thing with filmmaking is that
nothing until you're on set
shooting and even even when you're on
such shooting there's no guarantee that
the movie's going to get made
and i think if you have the mentality of
well i'm going to go on this thing's
going to get
made and it's going to get done it's
going to get finished you know you can
kind of shoot yourself in the foot that
way i think
if you just continue to work at it and
continue to
refine it and meet people and get the
right people involved
uh you know it's not until you're there
shooting that you can really go
okay now we can actually make this movie
because i've been in situations where
movies just fall apart completely and
the whole thing's already been shot
you know so it's not until the movie's
done that
you actually can go okay the movie's
made it's a miracle to me that any
movies get made in general because the
amount of red tape
and you know the amount of people that
you have to you have to get tons and
tons of people just on the same page
you're basically taking 100 people into
a room and you're saying all right we
all have to agree on the same thing
and not only that we all have to agree
on the same thing when it comes to art
and that's like really really hard to do
so so yeah i think it's a
it's definitely a tough tough experience
but you have to just keep at it
and you have to keep getting it into the
right hands and getting it to the right
people and knowing that
you know it can all come crashing down
and that if it does that that's okay
you know that's part of the process
there so i have tons of
films that you know never got finished
due to you
run out of money or you you know people
that were in it are gone and they
aren't available anymore or you know we
had a computer that just completely
crashed on us and we'd lose everything
so
there's a lot of of things uh you know
pushing against you when you're trying
to make a movie
do you think it was ironic that it was
called waiting for tomorrow
we made that joke a lot yeah we we found
ourselves constantly waiting for
tomorrow it was uh
it was us just kind of waiting for
people to call and
and we would get the phone call and we'd
be like oh this is great like we i just
had this great conversation and it's
leaning somewhere and then that
conversation
goes nowhere and then you have this
other great conversation with somebody
else and it's it's great and
things are moving forward and then that
goes nowhere but then sometimes you move
an inch forward every time and
so yeah it was it was very it became
very ironic
as as we started getting into the
process of getting it made
did you feel better for having gone
through this process or
did you have negative feelings maybe
depression as a result
yeah i think you know it is bad as it
sounds
depression is inevitable in this
industry and
it is not something i think you can
escape uh
and what i think is amazing about it
is that if you can sit there and
you know go through a depressive spout
i'm not good enough
i not talented enough you know i'm not
uh strong enough to do this
you know depression is a it's a fickle
thing because it makes you feel like
it's never going to end
and i think it's really important if you
sit there and you talk to yourself and
you go well you know what
i know this feeling and you recognize
that feeling you say
i know this feeling and i know that this
feeling is temporary and i know that no
matter what
i love what i'm doing and you kind of
have to check in with yourself you kind
of have to look around i mean even on
like the worst days on set
where you're just nothing is going right
you have to look around yourself and ask
yourself is there anything else you'd
rather be doing right now
and if the answer is no then you're
where you're supposed to be you know
if you could have written yourself an
email before the pitching process
and there were like these bullet points
what would you have told yourself in
terms of like
people in la won't tell you no and just
keep going or there are certain red
flags what were some of the
things on that list that you would have
liked to have read
that really would have helped i uh
that i think number one is that no is
like inevitable across the board
um it's really hard to get people to
get excited about ideas and and stories
and
and and scripts and and all that stuff
and you know you can hand somebody
a visual book of i mean we had this huge
book of waiting for tomorrow that was
just sort of a visual of like the entire
film
mapped out with like the colors and
everything what we wanted it to look
like
and people look through that they go wow
this is so great you put in so much work
but it's getting them
to put in the work i think is is really
really difficult so
i would say just i i would i would have
loved to read that that no is something
you're going to hear constantly
and no matter how successful you are
know is something that i think you'll
always hear
and to really
know to really understand the person
that you're going to
uh with a script i think is really
important there's something about
people just emailing each other pdfs
that feels very disingenuous
i think i think i'm very much a tactic
like a
analog person so i with waiting for
tomorrow we sent physical copies of the
script out to people
because there is something to be said
for sitting there and having a physical
copy of this thing and holding it in
your hands and feeling it
you know it it feels a lot more
real than just reading and scrolling it
on a computer and stuff like that
so with waiting for tomorrow
specifically we
did hard copies to send to everybody so
that's something for me that i would
have told myself because at first you
know you just send pdfs to people and it
and it
it is sort of feels very flat um but if
you can get a hard copy in somebody's
hands
i think that's that that does a lot for
people
um and then i think just understanding
that that
even if that person is incredibly
excited about your idea does not mean
that they want to
follow through and put all their time
and their energy into executing that
idea
and knowing that you are going to be the
one that's going to be doing the most
and then you just have to surround
yourself with people who are really
really good at taking things and
and and doing what they do best so
if that answers your question i think it
does
what prompted you to write the film and
you co-wrote it correct
yes yeah uh the waiting for tomorrow
uh a lot of it prompted
i mean me and my writing partner would
just write
a lot of stuff just to stay busy we
would write features and and tv shows
and
short films just because we wanted to
constantly stay busy and constantly
educate ourselves and get better at what
we do you know and
with waiting for tomorrow it was very
much
well let's just write a feature that we
could do that is doable
to a certain degree um so we just sort
of set out and and decided to tell the
story
about divorce from a child's perspective
being a child of divorce you know and
being a young a very
young child of divorce i think
that perspective tends to get lost so
for me it was really telling a story
about that and then adding in this sort
of
fantastical element that that you know
um allows you to sort of suspend your
disbelief and
and get let the movie kind of grab you
so we really wanted to tell something
that was sweet and kind
and not something that had this big
grandiose happy ending but more of an
ending that
that suggested that you know things are
going to get better and that things will
get better
and that it's important to keep moving
forward so yeah
did you have a script consultant look
over the script
we not we didn't have like any
professional script consultant we what
we did is
when jeff and i wrote the script we
would send it out
to a bunch of people and we would do
table reads of it
so you can actually hear what the
dialogue sounds like with people and
that's really helpful
i would um i would record myself for
reading
pieces of the dialogue of the script to
see if the dialogue sounded real
uh and not just scripted but yeah we we
sent it out to a lot of people who
were you know script writers and and and
storytellers who would give us their two
sense of what they thought and
and and just listen to their opinions
and listen to what their thoughts were
and make those changes or
do things like that while still trying
to stay true to us so it wasn't a script
consultant per se but it was just
a big group of people that we trusted
um that would give us good feedback you
know did anyone say hey man don't write
this down or you gotta
do horror with you know this this
element this element you know you don't
wanna
you wanna do something that's gonna make
people you know wanna get in the the
seats and
drink beer or whatever not not something
that where they'd actually have to think
yeah about oh sure yeah i think
uh you know we had one producer refer to
the film as like this like hallmark
movie which it wasn't like at all it's
it's a very
it's a coming-of-age story you know it's
it's it's a it's a story about this
this kid who basically feels completely
isolated and
doesn't speak to his father because he
feels like he wasn't heard at all
in when their parents were arguing in
the middle of their divorce he
felt well my voice doesn't matter so i'm
going to stop talking
and i think that with that it had a lot
of fun
really amazing elements i mean this kid
builds he builds he finds this old
broken down robot in this
backyard shed of this new house that
they move into and so he kind of builds
this thing up and he gets it to work
and it really it's the idea that it
doesn't really matter if it worked or
if it didn't what worked was that it
helped him
as a person um so it had a lot of comedy
and a lot of
stuff that was in it but i think some
people were like oh no you need to beef
up the action there's not enough action
and there's not enough
people to you know get meat in the seats
you know there's not enough of that
and and you know we just which is fine
you know
i don't think a movie necessarily needs
i think action's wonderful i think if
you do it right
it's brilliant but this movie itself
was to feel contained and was to feel
more intimate and more personal and
and more of a love letter to all the the
kids out there
who know what it's like to go through a
divorce as a young child and what that
does to you and and
and how that changes you so yeah we had
tons of people
make suggestions that you know
we're the opposite of what what we
wanted to do but but yeah
and then how soon after seeing that
maybe the script was not going to go
anywhere did you begin writing something
new
you and jeff i think yeah it was it was
about
i mean we always continued to write um
you know we took writing jobs that were
promised pay that
weren't paid and you know we continued
to just sort of
we always wanted to make sure that we
had one script sort of out there in
circulation and we would continue to
write new projects
there's always the thing that everybody
asks you which is you know this script
is great but what else do you have
i think it's important to have um a lot
of stories and for us for jeff and i we
just
would write to write you know and so we
were constantly
writing and and and constantly creating
short stories and
and features and stuff like that so it
was about once we got waiting for
tomorrow
finished that did take up a lot of our
attention
and so we we did the writing to sort of
take a back seat for a little bit
um but it was i would say say about
six months to a year
um of of of waiting for tomorrow once
that was finished that we started
writing other stuff and and
we started to to focus on on writing
other scripts and stuff like that
and didn't you have some big names
attached to the film to the screenplay
like
we did we had yeah we got a lot of
interest from from a lot of bigger names
and
and a lot of it came down to you know we
reached out i mean we
reached out to everybody under the sun
that we thought would be right for the
role
from c-list actors up to a-list actors
you know just shooting our shot you know
who knows but uh we did get a lot of
response from from a lot of of of
b-list i would say people and and people
who are just really really
good at what they do um and we had a lot
of like
oh they love the script they're really
interested a lot of the scheduling
was where we had to work out you know we
had a lot of we had a couple letter
lois which are letters of intent which
are basically them saying
that they agree to do the movie um uh
but that it's all financially contingent
based on what we have at the time and
what we're able to pay
and stuff like that so yeah we got a lot
of a lot of response from a lot of
people it was it was it was pretty
wonderful
so with this letter of intent did you
come up with a letter or did you have a
lawyer drafted
we had we were introduced to our
entertainment lawyer we have an amazing
entertainment lawyer um
bronstein braunstein and his name is
george bronstein he's
fantastic he is an
old-school entertainment lawyer who is
he does not beat around the bush
and he's got no sensor he he says he's a
really really wonderful guy
but yeah we went to him um we were
introduced to him through
another production company a friend of
ours who runs a production company
who they he did some stuff for them last
minute um
so they introduced us and and and we
made a great relationship with them and
and so we went to him and basically said
you know we need you know
letters of intent and and we need to
write up contracts and and stuff like
that so that was stuff that he
was willing to do quick and easy and and
get it all done and
and stuff like that so and he knows you
know he knows that world better than any
of us and
this was our you know first foray into
the red tape of filmmaking like the
the really really like oh you have to
have all of these
you know crossing your eyes and dot your
t's you know it all has to be
so he really really helped us out in
getting us uh
the the letters that we needed and the
contracts that we needed and
and and helped us uh seem
uh helped us reach a level of
professionalism that we wouldn't have
been able to do by ourselves
and did you get an imdb pro account how
did you find
which sort of like representative to
send yeah
all of it was done through imdb some
some of it was done through
friends of friends who knew people i
mean we we would
we would talk to this person who knew
this person who knew
kevin bacon you know six degrees of
kevin bacon but um you know it
so it was those kinds of things where we
said would you give them this or would
you give them that and
it takes months and months and months
before people even can sit down and
read any of your stuff and i'm sure
these people had scripts piling up at
their door and what made ours
special you know so a lot of it was also
through through imdb pro yeah we set up
a pro account and reached out to
managers and
and agencies and and and you know were
very upfront about the project and who
we were you know we were nobodies
we know we still are nobodies you know
so getting
a script from us it doesn't really mean
much um but hopefully
we would hope that they would read the
script and they would find something
about it that they would connect with
and and be willing to to
go forward and so yeah it was all
through imdb pro and
and friends of friends of friends and
and whatnot
what advice can you give someone on
reaching out to talent let's suppose
there's a script and they're like you
know this is my dream actor for it
what advice is less more you know when
you when you begin the email or the
letter is it better to keep it brief
sure yeah i think um i don't know i
don't think there's a rule
as far as i mean obviously you know when
we reached out
to to agencies and managers you know we
would give them sort of
a booklet we made sort of a package
booklet of
of the script that was consistent with
the script um sort of a visual guide um
concept artwork we kind of put the whole
thing together in a little package that
they could then look at
very easily rather than having to do a
bunch of emails back and forth
and you know at the end of the day
they're they're looking out for
themselves and they're looking out for
their client so
if they look at something and they think
that there is no monetary value behind
it
um a lot of the times they're not going
to follow through or a lot of the times
they'll say they read something and
then they didn't you know but yeah i
would say just
be as honest and
and and forthcoming about about who you
are and what you do and what you love
and and why you think
their client is the best person for the
role um for us it was really about
you know why we thought that person
could pull this role off and why we
thought
why we would love to see that actor take
on a role like this
um you know just for for our own
personal interest you know
so yeah i don't think there's a length
to it i think just be genuine and
and and tell them what you want and and
what you have and just
let the package that you build sort of
speak for itself
has anyone ever told you oh don't say
that that's being too honest that's
being too real
they'll think you're too new and you
said you know what i just want to stay
yeah sure yeah yeah there's times where
you know people rely
there's a lot of times when we're
reaching out to sort of bigger actors
that we would constantly have people
like proofread an email
is this good is this okay like does it
sound right is it grammarly is it is
is the grammar correct um but
a lot of the times you know it it
i would just reach out to these people
and be as honest as i possibly could and
not try and talk myself up not try and
talk up
my company not trying to do any of that
but really just get people
involved in the story because that's
really what
we're talking about you know we're not
talking about
who i am and and and what i've done even
though that does
it does play a factor there was a lot of
times where people were like who the
hell is this person we don't know who
they are
delete um and you get that a lot but but
there are people out there who
if they can engage with with the story
that you're presenting them with
um you know that that really is is is
what's important so we never really had
anybody be like
oh don't word it this way because they
might find it offensive or they might
find this too
abrasive or too abrupt i think just be
you and and reach out because
because honesty i think in situations
like that is crucial and really
you know getting the other side to
understand where it is that you're
coming from and what you want to do and
what not so yeah
you